Yeah.
There was like a lead XC.
And then,
um,
you know,
and strike force,
those were two legit venues outside the UFC.
That really kind of,
because the UFC wasn't as big back then.
Right.
And then they,
they were pretty legit.
There were more men.
You could get it.
You didn't have to pay per view it.
Right.
You could actually just watch him,
which is what Bella has going for it too.
But now Bella Torres on that new thing does zone DAZN do you know what that is?
What they're doing is they're splitting,
it's like a streaming service.
They're splitting half the half the fights.
Uh,
Bella tore on paramount,
which is used to be spike paramount.
Half the fights on this DAZN network.
But what's crazy is the DAZN network just gave Canelo Alvarez $365 million.
They just gave him this giant deal because they had were fighters.
No Canelo just one.
You just beat triple g unconcerned about boxing.
You know what I'm saying?
I have blocks.
You know what?
I fully left it.
We went to your place once.
Your old house,
maybe you,
I don't know,
maybe a couple other people.
We were watching some pride stuff that you DVR,
right.
And it cut off the last fight cause it went long.
Oh that's right.
And then we watched boxing kickboxing.
And after watching two hours of MMA,
you see a guy get knocked down and they're just like,
go to work at a word.
Let them get up.
You're like,
what the fuck is this?
So much hugging and fucking boxing socks.
It's great if you watch really good boxers and if you'd know you're going to go
see boxing Canelo Alvarez fight.
That happened a couple of weeks ago.
It was a really good fight.
I thought triple G ma.
Well I thought it was a real close fight,
but if I was going to give it to someone,
I think I would've given it to triple j but it was close enough where you can
go,
okay,
this isn't a robbery but good fight.
We need decisions but leg kicks and and and take downs.
And it just makes fighting more interest as I was just way too many fucking,
let's see what the judges said.
No one.
So nobody really one.
They just got just did better.
Yeah.
Beto Guy.
Right?
Rare.
I mean,
it happens,
but rarely it happens less.
Yeah.
The thing about Pacquiao,
Mayweather was like,
Amica kept fighting,
right.
So what have we decided?
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
After 12 rounds,
they could've gone 12 I like the early pride,
like the early UFC with like hoist.
It's like,
yeah,
you're gonna find me for 35 minutes.
Right.
And then we'll see.
Eventually I'll fucking wear you down.
Yeah.
That's what Nate always says.
Like if this was war,
you'd be dead.
Yeah.
Like I choked her out.
That means I would have kept choking you.
Yeah.
And then just put a fucking,
you know,
twisted your neck.
Yeah.